I mean I know you had thyroid cancer I
had the cancer yes I mean is I you know
when I hear the word thyroid and cancer
it just sounds like that's not a good
cancer to
have you know it's not a bad cancer to
have uh I mean if you're have cancer
it's super treatable um if you catch it
on time the problem is if you don't
catch it if you don't know you have it
it can spread to your lungs pretty
quickly um I got crazy lucky I got saved
uh I went to a
masseuse I went for a full relaxation
massage and at the end of the massage
she massaged my neck and I was like what
is she doing no one ever does that like
the front of my neck and at the end of
the massage my full relaxation massage
she told me she felt a lump and I was
like well that's not relaxing and then
I I didn't even think anything of it and
like three months later I went to the my
physical IAL and my doctor was like you
know he checked me up and down and he
was like you know at the end of the
session he was like is there anything
else you want to tell me and I was like
you know I went to this masseuse and she
told me I had a lump on my neck I don't
know and he felt my neck and he was like
there's two there's two lumps and I was
like oh [__] um concerned he looked he
looked concerned well it was concerning
at the time as you can imagine um but
you know it was so it came after I had
had a nervous breakdown that
year which all was because of the
thyroid like your thyroid stops
functioning and you get crazy depressed
and like it really messes with your head
um so I it kind of was like a relief I
was like oh that's why I've been
freaking out is like I've had I'm not
healthy like I'm not physically okay and
um and it was kind of like that year was
so crazy that just being told I had
cancer was like well of course I have
cancer in fact I went out I went out to
dinner with John herwitz who created
Cobra Kai and the Harold and Kumar
movies and I told him I said you're not
going to believe this but I I have
cancer and he said of course you have
cancer I guess people just expect me to
be sickly but um that's terrible and
even just of course yeah yeah I thought
it was bad in the moment too I didn't I
didn't think it was funny but looking
back it was and uh and anyway I caught
it and it's super treatable and I still
in contact I found the
masseuse and I'm still in contact with
her I sent her a bunch of gifts she
saved my life and she didn't have to do
that and uh a little bit of an Angel
there and uh but like the the problem is
you lose your thyroid they removed my
whole thyroid right so I became super um
super fat is that what happens when you
lose your thyroid you get fat I don't
know how these things work I'm severely
hypothyroid and what that means is like
I'm on the highest dose of the medicine
that people take to replace their
thyroid which is called
Synthroid and
uh even with that dose man like I cannot
eat without gaining like tremendous
amounts of weight really fast like what
was the height of your
weight uh 23 that make sense the height
of your weight the height of my weight
the weight of my height uh
232 at 5
foot6
my the average weight or the recommended
weight for a person that's 5 foot6 is
155 so 232 that was pretty overweight
right now being an actor and being in
Hollywood and look I think you're one of
the the best I think you're you're
tremendous I think you know I we can get
into that no but I just I really really
respect your work and even seeing
like highlights of uh Leopold schot is
that how you pronounce it am you know
that you put on Instagram I believe yeah
I put one I was I was I was blown away I
was like he's English
he's he's this character I haven't seen
you play something like that and you
know you got a drama League award get
nominated for a drama League award for
that and I'm like you know I always
thought you were a great actor but I was
like oh my gosh look at this he's on
Broadway he's [__] a Broadway this a
[__] actor but let me my my question
is you know when you're 232 pounds I'm
sure people are kind of like on your
Instagram are looking God this that guy
got that guy got fat he's yeah really
what what happened were you aware like
were you like were you embarrassed by or
you were just like do you you are
embarrassed by it yeah well I wish I'd
never been skinny you know or because
then people wouldn't do that but like
when I did like numbers for instance
like I was super skinny and then you
know you get big later in life for
whatever reason you know and people yeah
people are mean about it um I don't know
embarrassed maybe I I was disappointed
in myself and frustrated because it
wasn't like I was overeating it was just
I was gaining weight regardless and that
was really tough as an actor like if I
wasn't an actor I guess I wouldn't care
that much like it's unhealthy but I
wouldn't like have Lo like tried to lose
a lot of weight you you're not the
Limelight as much you're not like you
know at all when you're not an actor you
don't have to think about live in New
Jersey [__] it I'm Jersey skinny the 232
is third is you know Jersey athletic but
um uh yeah an actor it started to really
bother me especially because it just
felt like oh no like I'm
not going to get up I'm going to lose
opportunities and and then what happened
was you know I got a lot of like
opportunities to play chunky guys but
then there's always some like ribbing in
all these scripts you know like oh the
fat guy and you know and I was like wow
I guess that's that's what I've got to
do is is just be the big guy suddenly